good evening thank you for having me
first of all do you accept that China
has a problem with trust the world
simply at the moment doesn't seem to
trust China I don't think so
I think we have a good record you know
China is the first country to report
awareness and first to identify the
pathogen first to share genetic sequence
with the tablet oh and many other
countries at a record short time when
you say the world I can't you know I
agree with you I think only a few
countries that challenge okay and if
some make some accusation with no
grandpa oh okay well let's look at why
some of the world may not trust China
let's go to the beginning and according
to your own state news agency dr. Jang
Shi Shan reported her suspicions of the
virus to the authorities on December the
27th she suspected human-to-human
transmission because she treated a
couple in Wuhan and then their son but
it was not until the 22nd of January
nearly four weeks later that China
through the w-h-o confirmed
human-to-human transmission why was
there such a delay that's not sure you
know we are once dr. Jeong as you
mentioned jong-kyun
reported to their local Health Authority
on 23rd then they four days later
Chinese authorities health authorities
notified awh CEO office in Beijing that
was four days later than they on 3rd of
January that was seven days later wait
officially you know the the Health
Commission they hire the central
government authorities for health
notified officially
waho and you know since this is a it's a
new virus it's unknown to not only to
the world but also to China we have to
be responsible we adopt we have adopted
a cautious approach try our very best so
eleven days later we identified the
pathogen and share the genetic sequence
without delay at all so I think it's a
rare but the WHI late so well the wh o
timeline says clearly that it was
January the 22nd that they confirmed
human to human transmission and this
doctor told Xinhua your news agency and
I quote it is unlikely that all three
members of a family caught the same
disease at the same time unless it is an
infectious disease so on December the
27th she knew and the authorities in
Wuhan knew but it wasn't until the 22nd
that the w-h-o confirmed it was human to
human transmission I said you know it
will take some process even so you know
we have lost no time in informing whu-oh
once we know there's a risk of
transmission from human to human
and I have you know they talk to June
who is the most authoritative authority
in this field he said in the press
briefing on 20 on 20th of January
earlier than your timeline and that
that's a risk high risk that of the
transmission from people to people but
at that time this about a hundred about
less than 200 cases in China right so
you know it take time I think for any
countries you can't you you know there's
a certain procedure
in terms of determining the infectious
disease that is a responsible way to
handle this case
yeah I understand that so why was dr.
Lee when yang why was he arrested and
silenced when he wrote on social media
about his fears about the spread of the
disease first Lee was never arrested as
a some medium reported in violence and
told to retract yo he was assignment to
police station I recommend because as I
said you know once you have some
infectious disease authorities any any
other countries including here UK you
know you have to be careful you have to
be responsible you do not want to create
a panic as I said three days earlier
before even them dr. Jang reported to
the health authorities then the local
health authorities report to the central
government then central government
notified wh oh you know that was four
days later and was one day after Lee
though there's no kebab there's no
so-called persecution and the Lee
himself you know because there's so many
things happen and the government take
care attach importance to this complaint
and the sent investigation team are down
to Han okay find out what your he going
on it was me to matter what's made here
on okay let's look at another reason why
the world may not trust China Mike
Pompeo the US Secretary of State says
you failed to share information about
the virus Donald Trump says he's
promising a report soon saying there is
quotes enormous evidence that covered 19
began in the whoo-hah and laboratories
and he quotes his quote is my opinion is
they made a mistake and they tried to
cover it up so my question is was it a
mistake and did you try to cover it up
as it said there's no any come up at all
we shared information with the whu-oh
and the world without delay and we
notify united states from the very
beginning on the 30th of January 1 we
notify the public heo we also notified
CVC of United State and since then
there's a tail a communications a tail a
briefing between the Chinese CDC and
American CDC 1 you say that the world I
don't think what said by United States
either their national leaders whether
top diplomat represent the world that's
not the truth then here's a comment from
China
let me quote it on a truck you know on
the march of 27th after his composition
helped in composition with the
presidency he said that was just one
month ago he said we learned quite a lot
and China had a very tough experience we
learned a lot from China we have a good
communications and they sent a lot of
data from you know we receive a lot of
data from China do you have a early
experience and we are getting all that
information
no that was Donald Trump it was really
deep and and wear your coat again okay
now whatever reason then let me look at
another reason the world may not trust
China you're refusing to open up for a
full investigation an international
investigation by scientists if you have
nothing to hide and as you say there's
no cover-up why not allow an
international investigation of the lab
and the wet market and other places an
international investigation why not when
you say international organization I
think these investigations should be not
politically motivated I think first of
all now the top priority for the
international community is to fight is
to focus on fighting these various
happen to agree with your secretary when
he said hundred percent of the focus
would be working together to fight
against these birds you know secondly
we're open we are transparent we have
nothing to hide
we're nothing to fear you know we we
welcome international independent review
but it has to be you know organized by
w-h-o it should be international well
you say did you agree to that would you
agree to the w-h-o organizing
international scientists from across the
world to come into China to investigate
would you agree to that
yes yes property you will appropriate
but not now we certainly work out well
you know the purpose is to compare notes
to summarize to learn experience how can
we do better for future pandemic well
that's the purpose doesn't it's not to
allow birds china isn't it best they
have things that we respect ambassador
with respect four and a half million
people have been infected by this virus
nearly 300,000 people have died as a
result of this virus which you concede
probably came from Wuhan in your country
it is a global tragedy that has been
caused here doesn't it need a global
investigation now as soon as possible
with world-renowned scientists I think
that scientists expert of working even
now I think this scientist from China
scientists from United States from UK
are working to find the origin I think
when you say that you know the this
outbreak happened in China but China is
the first to report the case but you
can't say the virus originated from
China it's a stool it's a matter of it's
up to the scientists origin
I'm using the word origin in is the
first case was in China it's not the
first time it happened with SARS it's
happened with Co vyd it cannot be
allowed to happen again
definitely it cannot be happened again
but this is a very still unknown to many
scientists right so you can't blame
China China China is a victim that is
another culprit of this virus it's not
it's not a man Middlebury's you know
it's natural in origin so we have to
adopt a scientific approach you know you
can't you can't have this earth campaign
of us stigmatizing if information smear
against China as some American
politicians well I understand my project
allow scientists well allow scientists
in and they would find out the truth
most modern fair-minded open responsible
countries would let international
scientists in very quickly we are
working with a scientist from you know
international community there's no doubt
about that but you have you have to
separate from the political multi
so-called independent investigations you
know when you see the world
there's only few countries United States
Australia so your name how many
countries can give me you can give me
ten countries to call for the so-called
independent diversification I think many
countries call for the global response
call for solidarity cooperation call for
constructive not a tryst achill critical
you know I think the theme of the today
is to focus on fighting okay
this varies and the save lives okay
instead of playing this game of play
blaming and sting coaching okay why is
China or Chinese backed groups trying to
steal corona virus research according to
the intelligence agencies they say
you're hacking British and American
scientists working on Co vid programs
why why would you want to do that where
do you get this charges again do you
have a proof the
the FBI say and I quote the hackers have
been observed attempting to obtain
illicit ly public health data this is
not the first time that United States
made such a fabrication and the force
acquisition against China currently you
know I think this is a not only there
Atlas to undermine the international
collaboration on working together to
find the vet the vaccine
I think vaccine will be the final
solution to the problem and Chinese
scientists working around the clock
first on their own then engage in
collaboration with the United States
even scientists planet from US and China
and the UK also working very closely
both our top leaders President Xi and
Prime Minister Johnson you know give us
a hot ok to this or talk about a vaccine
ambassador talking about a vaccine if
China discovers a vaccine before other
countries do you agree to distribute it
equitably and fairly along the lines
advised by the vaccine Alliance yes we
certainly like to share you know our we
regard this as the the joint efforts of
the international scientists you know we
we should share this to enhance the
global response since this verse says
their policy why that's why we are
engaging with other countries yeah in
collaboration on science so that policy
that policy is that it goes first to
those at the heart of the outbreak
wherever it is in the world and then it
goes to health workers around the world
China will agree to that will it agree
to what agree with the policy that is if
you come up with a vaccine it should go
first to those at the heart of an
outbreak around the world and secondly
to health workers around the world you
agree to that in principle we certainly
you know I think it's still early
to say what's in specific 10 because we
we haven't you know made the vaccine yet
though China has been very advanced now
in terms of developing the vaccine but I
said as a principle we would like to
share what we have achieved with other
countries either in the most anemic
countries all to the frontline medical
workers ok yes as what we have done to
provide medical supplies to many took
about a hundred fifty countries I think
most of these medical supplies have been
used in the frontline workers including
here you okay you know we are donating
the medical the most needed supplies we
have the UK government to prepare
ventilators I think they are all have
been cooked in good use okay peace
offering
okay now you've talked openness you've
talked about openness let's just talk
about that why have you expelled
13 American journalists from China many
of whom were trying to investigate the
origin of the virus that's point one and
why have to citizen journalists who put
out videos at the very beginning of this
fan bin and Chen Xiu Shi
why have they disappeared where are they
you should ask why American expel 60
Chinese journalists from United States
and you should ask why we have a given
more preferential treatment to American
journalism you know we have been forced
to make a counter method is there's
nothing to do with their COBIT 19 as I
said China has been open okay you know
mr. ambassador as far as I know America
doesn't imprison journalists you've
imprisoned 48 in the last year more than
any other country how is that how is
that openness journalist no journalist
is a you know put into view behind the
bar because what they are doing as a
journalist people are put behind Barbie
cuz they are violating the law nobody is
above
everybody is treated equal in front of
law so you can't you can't to use the
journalism as a you know cover to do
something that your while eight law the
answer is simple
okay and you're a country of over a
billion people and yet you have less
than five thousand fewer than five
thousand official deaths too many people
that seems unbelievable is it true
that's because we have adopt most strict
a comprehensive vigorous of rigid
measures in contain the virus you know
so we want to share with this you know
one day the Wuhan the city which is five
times of London with a population eleven
million which is a bigger than Linden
plaster Northern Ireland one day the
tongue was locked for six seventy stays
new people made a huge sacrifice you
know that the birds you know as I said
this virus is about suspicion from
people to people so the lockdown has
been to be very effective message and
also we have there we have these
effective measures what we call it for
others early diagnosis early treatment
you know early quarantine testing so
write all these tend to be you can't
blame China for come up because we have
a low number of dead cases no I'm not
leaving I'm not blaming you mister
ambassador for anything I'm just gonna
make the point finally I'm going to ask
you in the UK we've had over 30,000
deaths with a much smaller population
obviously where do you think Britain
went wrong I do not want to be critical
over York a policy but I what I want to
say is we would like to share our
experience compare notes with a British
colleague I just want to give you the
first-hand information tomorrow
secretary Matt Hancock will have an
online meetings
where the British scientists experts
where the Chinese Health Minister you
know it will be more than two hours
discussions to compare knows compare to
experience I think that is what we need
now we need to enhance collaboration we
have to know this various is our common
enemy so we need to pull together we
should came to the aid to each other to
win the final battle I think as a
present she said solidarity cooperation
are the most powerful weapons for
international community - okay a Cobra
okay mr. ambassador I appreciate your
time and I look forward to the
international investigation whenever it
should happen thank you very much indeed
for joining us this evening and
answering our questions thank you
medical issue